It's not just a job.
It's sort of, probably the most important job.
The title that we have going right now is Director of Operations,...
...but it's really kinda so much more than that.
Responsibilities and requirements are really quite extensive.
First category for the requirements would be mobility.
This job requires that you must be able to work,...
...standing up most or really all of the time,...
...constantly on your feet, constantly bending over,...
...constantly exerting yourself, a high level of stamina.
Okay.
That's a lot.
For how many hours?
135 hours to unlimited hours a week.
It's basically 24 hours a day, 7 days a week.
I'm sure you'll have a chance from time to time...
...to maybe just sit down here and there, yeah?
You mean, like a break?
No, there are no breaks available.
Is that even legal?
Yeah, of course, yeah.
Okay.
So like, no lunch?
You can have lunch, but only when the associate is done eating their lunch.
I think that's a little intense.
Also, let's cover the salary.
The position is gonna pay absolutely nothing.
Excuse me?
No!
Nobody's doing that for free!
Yeah, pro bono.
Completely for free.
No!
What if I told you there's someone that actually...
...currently holds this position right now?
Billions of people actually.
Who?
Moms.
That's awesome.